can we read two articles I'm sending you
one of them uh that's coming your way
but let me read this one this is MB this
is CNN NBC News polls uh report on
papelosi's attack NBC news on Friday
pulled a report about the Pelosi attack
uh that the network did not meet the
standards the peace should not have
aired because it did not meet NBC's news
reporting standards and editor said uh
in place of storyline episode the
package from National correspondents
Miguel made assertions that were
attributed to on a unnamed sources and
appear to raise questions about the
circumstances of the attack a network
source told CNN it pulled the segment
after the source of the reporters
information was found to be unreliable
the decision was not made was made to
remove the segment afterwards determined
shortly after the rare that the main
source for the information was
unreliable regarding the questions of
circumstances that the police
encountered when they aired at the house
especially specifically what the police
saw and how far the attacker was from
the door okay I mean that's kind of
weird for NBC to do that and then
Reuters wrote this which is kind of
weird for Reuters even writers fact
Checkers existing records do not show
Paul Pelosi's alleged attacker David
told investigators they engage in sexual
relations and argued over drugs
interesting to even put this up there
for Reuters some social media users are
saying that David the suspect in the 20
October 20 attack on papelosi told
investigators that the two engage in
sexual relations over our drugs without
providing proof of claim however there
is no publicly available evidence that
debate the paper made these statements
to officials one Twitter user sharing
the claim said David tells investigators
that he and Paul were engaging in gay
sex and in argument in suit over drugs
and but official records and statements
do not support the claim uh that uh the
baby told the investigators he was
engaged in sexual relation with Pelosi
the husband of U.S speaker and it's okay
so so this is this is this is what's
spreading right now and Don Lemon uh
somebody was telling the story Donna was
like I can't believe they're doing this
and uh you know this some people are
saying this was really going on they're
trying to hide this from the public well
look I mean the reason that this the sex
thing started was there was a report by
Fox 10. now this is not by the way the
Fox News Channel this is not a right
wing so this is the local Fox reporting
station and a reporter who's in San
Francisco in San Francisco yes uh Fox 10
in San Francisco and the local uh report
are covering the story very reliable guy
said that not only was Paul Pelosi in
his underwear but so was the attacker
think about this for a minute yeah so
you're thinking wait a minute Paul
Pelosi is in his underwear okay it's his
house it's 2 A.M in the morning he's
sleeping you're sleeping in a suit and
tie of course you're in underwear but
the idea that the attackers in his
underwear was like whoa what the hell's
going on there so that's what started
leading to the idea that this was some
kind of Rendezvous that went sideways or
something then they corrected that they
said oh that's not the case he wasn't in
his underwear so as far as I know this
thing got dropped the sex thing got
dropped right and stopped talking about
it now the NBC thing is more telling
because if you look at the NBC report
and the guy is obviously not trying to
get Pelosi or get he's he's just
reporting right he makes two points that
are damaging first of all he says that
when when when Paul Pelosi came to the
door and the and and met the cops
instead of exiting the the apartment he
turned around and returned to the quote
scene of the crime where he was then
attacked and that right away raises the
question that was Paul Pelosi even did
he even feel threatened by this guy if
not why would you walk back into his
vicinity and the second thing they said
was that even though the police were at
the Pelosi residence
they didn't know it was Pelosi's
residence they didn't even know it was
Nancy Pelosi's husband so in other words
it'd make them look like idiots so so
the NBC report was damaging to the cops
and it was damaging to Paul Pelosi and
so that's my point is is my question is
when NBC doesn't meet our standards is
that they don't meet your standards of
Truth or they don't meet your standards
of not fitting The Narrative and making
the Pelosi's look bad and therefore you
took it down can you pull up the windows
can you pull up the glass window shatter
just type in glass window Paul Pelosi
click on images there's there's one
thing that's a little weird uh when you
look at this go click on it and uh go to
go to zoom in zoom in on that one the
one that you have the one that you just
okay that one right there if someone's
breaking in when you break the window
and you hit it glass goes the other way
why is glass coming out
do you get what I'm saying so I don't
just make sense what I'm asking go on
another picture maybe we can have a
better angle like if I'm trying to break
into a house that's a CSI question yeah
so if I'm breaking into a house and I'm
cracking and look I'm a military guy but
I'm not a CSI guy if I hit the window
with the hammer to break in glass should
go in not out
but why is it coming out it's kind of a
little weird let me look at that so
where are you going with that maybe the
guy was trying to get out from Paul I
got to get out of here I don't know man
yeah I'm not saying he's trying to get
up you can't see how much glass is on
the inside there's only a little bit of
Glass on the outside I don't know where
the glass thing I'll tell you what
upsets me there's like this this is
where like rumors and conspiracy
theories kind of go down a rabbit hole
Dinesh
okay let's say they're both under
something freaking weird this guy's 82
years old he's married to Nancy for the
God for five decades now there's zero
stories out there correct me if I'm
wrong for the last 50 years he's been in
the public eye that he's at any weird
sexual gay stuff Tendencies any of that
and you're gonna wait till you're 82
years old a week before midterms with
some [ __ ] delusional guide that's
where you're gonna seize the moment to
do a little sword fighting and it seems
so weird to me
maybe it's just now breaking you know
you've not been married to Nancy Pelosi
for five seconds it's not like he's
married to Melania Trump right
the point is do you have
do you have credibility to this gay sex
story no I don't now um when I first
heard the double underwear story I was
like hmm that's interesting look let me
let me put it this way I think that this
story is coming at a time when people
have developed a deep distrust of our
public institutions
yeah and it happened slowly but it's
it's now very far Advanced people don't
believe the media I think with with a
lot of justification they don't believe
the FBI no they don't they only believe
their media they believe their media
okay they don't believe the other side
they only believe their side yeah they
don't but they don't trust the CDC I
mean they're up you know you can't trust
scholarly journals these days think
about it journalists like the Lancet
have admitted this is the most
prestigious medical journal in the world
has admitted that they have published
doctor data that they have known things
were false and published them because
they quote serve the public good you
know these you have these top scientists
say saying we we don't know we're not
involved of gain of function research
turns out that they do know they are
involved uh you know they're making
these deadly viruses and we knew nothing
about it for over a year even after
covet you know
um then they never seriously consider
where this virus comes from so suddenly
people look at this and again now
they're in the past you'd have a San
Francisco police chief this is what
happened and they'd be like yeah okay
that's what happened you know and and I
was like that too I mean because science
has even got politicized these days and
without trusted science trusted science
then you see what's happened with covet
or even like global warming it's like I
will say I will say this when you say
stuff like he's never had anything in
the past stuff like that the guy just
got a DUI like a few weeks ago I mean
you're talking about an 82 year old guy
that just got a DUI
I'd love to know what is the oldest DUI
in the history of America can you pull
it up like who's the oldest person ever
did he he deserves the right to be in a
Guinness Book of World Records
are you staying there oh no no if you're
acting irresponsibly lately so if you're
saying the guy doesn't have a track
record you have a track record of just a
few weeks ago getting a DUI yes you are
acting irresponsibly that doesn't mean
the short fight I'm not talking about
that yeah but all I'm saying to you is
the track record is recent you've been
acting irresponsibly getting a DUI well
you know where I stand on DUIs I feel
like you should be like fully overlift
yeah just like these days if you get a
DUI especially that's a different
discussion let's not get sidetracked but
my point is all I'm saying has nothing
to do with no all the underwear
sexy no no you said does he have a track
record
I'm not saying gayness I'm telling you
being irresponsible okay being
irresponsible he has a track record of
being a response doubt he has a track
record responsible for the stocks that
they're doing there's so many things
spending his he doesn't have the biggest
moral Authority and credibility right
now so if you like this clip and you
want to watch watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]